long time Boston Globe columnist Bob
riot how you doing Bob hey good thank
you so when Gordon Hayward went down in
a heap what did you think about the
chances of the Celtics this season that
they would still be able to keep their
head above water make the playoffs
perhaps when they won 53 last year I
would say you know 48 49 something but
make the playoffs get a mid-range seed
maybe maybe get lucky you can get a four
but you know they might be playing that
first round on the road the whole thing
and but they weren't the ripped they
weren't stripped of talent and I thought
if this if that and and so forth I also
here's the other thing which that's the
one position that they had depth they
had real depth and in numbers and then
MIT at that point they didn't have
Marcus Morris yet but we knew he was
coming and and they were going to have
some numbers at that position and and
but what's happened is beyond anyone's
imagination there's so far no one no one
starting with Brad Stevens who's
cautioning people you know we have to
play better offense which is true to
keep this thing going
no one saw what's it coming so you know
it wasn't finally they had Irving and
this is gonna and I I wrote about at a
time okay Kyrie you wanted to be the man
well you this is it for you you've got
your chance now and and he has his
answer develop he sure has it really is
amazing let's get into it though what
Stephens because so much obviously you
know Belichick gets all the the pub
there and Francona got a lot of pub when
he was winning championships with the
Red Sox Stevens hasn't won a
championship yet isn't even won a
conference championship yet but what
have you seen from him what does he do
to make this thing work the way that he
has since coming out of Butler you know
there isn't any secret sauce but would
it he has shares in common now this is
my you know from the so-called
professional judgment while observing
coaches and all sports for over 40 years
40 45 years that the common ingredient
of the really successful coaches and
it's starting what they got to have
talent you know and we're talking about
people who accomplished something and
they're not just making chicken salad at
a chicken you know what but people who
have some talent to start with but the
whole thing is do they buy what you're
selling and can you sell it properly and
can you convince them that what you're
going to tell them it will work this is
what Belichick does
and this is what pop does this is what
you can go down a list of over football
other coaches I'm sure it's what Scotty
Bowman did I'm sure it's what what Joel
Quenneville does so I mean they these
guys have it there's a certain it some
guys don't some guys are lieutenants who
can't be a general we think we've that's
that phenomenon exists in every sport
that every time and and and they get
exposed quickly there's one in New York
City Yale coaching to a certain football
team you know that he's a lieutenant
he's not a general but and you don't
know until you give him the try every
successful famous coach of history how
to have a first job how to have a
training ground somewhere but that's all
it is to it he he recognizes talent he
puts people in a position that do their
best and whatever he sells on a daily
basis however he carries himself he you
know he's not a phony I learned from my
good friend he'll be brown years ago you
have to be true to your personality you
have to be whatever it is in this case
it's a relatively low-key one it's a
low-key laid-back Midwestern one from
Zionsville Indiana and and he isn't
trying to be anybody other than who he
is and one thing I give I'll shut your
talking unlike certain other it's not
about the Eagle players no when the
coach thinks it's about him I think they
know and that and they never like that
and not on a professional level you can
get away with that in college but but
and and he they know he doesn't think
it's about him so it works
DirecTV 4k NBA report here on the Rich
Eisen show Bob Ryan kind enough to call
in to provide some an insight here
certainly for the red-hot Boston Celtics
here on the Rich Eisen show and in terms
of that 15 wins and or just the 17 games
that we've seen already for the Celtics
Bob I mean that the season opening loss
they they'd still damn near won that
game yeah rich Gordon Hayward went down
and and you could you could just excuse
that the team would be lost in in that
and then certainly in the next game
trying to figure out how to put all the
pieces together and then in this win
streak the fact that they beat the
Warriors to now that was kind of the
showstopper for me because I'm looking
to see how we are not all on the the NBA
Titanic ready to just hit that's
warriors reef by June anyway
just rearranging deck chairs until then
what did you read into that
Celtics 100 17 down with the 90 no run I
think that's done that the people who
follow that team I was watching Twitter
that night they were like they were
having a the minds were just screwed up
you know you and you want to use the
f-word but you know I mean it was nobody
nobody runs a 90 no run on the Warriors
I think what the Celtics did they were
in 1900 which means you need both ends
of the floor that they would accomplish
what you did and they did it and they
got back in the game that way and then
you know they showed the same kind of
spunk you know that they've shown again
in other games they start its they've
now come from 17 down three times in
this streak or 15 at least I think 17 is
true but I might be wrong but well mid
mid double-digit deficits have been
overcome three times okay I'll settle
for that and they did it against the
Warriors and and who worked full
strength you know it were that night
they were at full strength curry played
curry was terrible was 3 for 14 klay
Thompson was 5 for 18 this they were 8
for 32 between them meanwhile Irving was
4 for 14 himself so you know he wasn't
so great but well here's let me just
they finally won the game though in a
classic NBA fashion they have the
virtuoso superstar he went to the basket
nobody touched him he went to the line
made two free throws and if Terry Rozier
had made that same drive to the basket I
promise you the whistle would not have
blown but that's that's why you want
guys like that on your team Bob Ryan the
Boston Globe here on the show ask him
the poll question Christopher this is
Chris from Maine asking Boston which
team the start of the year oh and 2 is
the best chance to win their respective
title oh and two Saints now have won
eight straight or they own two Celtics
of now on 15 stories well cuz I'm
involved in both into that because the
team that they would eventually have to
beat would be the New England Patriots
more than likely not necessarily but
more than likely and I they're not
beaten the Patriots play just beat the
crap out of them the first time and I
know that they're the rematch is are
often very different but I I would like
to think the Celtics and Patriots would
prevail over them if that's who they
were wound up lame because they're
playing anybody but the Patriots then
they'd ever shot so I'll have to go
Celtics but I but that's only to answer
that question I am not calling the
Celtics to win I'm not even calling them
to beat the Cavaliers until
I am totally satisfied two Cavaliers
aren't going to get it together with
Manchester guys in with people wouldn't
that people telling me they can't get it
together their personnel this year in
this group won't allow it
they're not going to be able to play the
defense they need to play it's not going
to happen LeBron is going to have to be
beyond Superman to carry them through
this year that's what some people think
but I'm not buying that yet I'm gonna
withhold well especially since the other
part of that trade really hasn't I mean
Jake routers been there but everyone's
kind of waiting for the Boston Jake
router to step up and show himself in a
consistent basis in Cleveland we haven't
seen IT what he's gonna look like there
wouldn't that be interesting to see him
put wind beneath the the wings of the
Cavs in the same way that carries done
for the Celtics but would and it would
be such great theater and I would be
looking forward to that series for that
reason and I mean you know he's such a
great little competitor I mean he was so
liked here and loved here and and and
and yep people it was a bittersweet
thing losing him from Cooper but you're
gaining you're gaining a true superstar
in Irving no I wouldn't I would be
remiss if I didn't ask you about the
Patriots before I let you go even though
again we're in the DirecTV 4k NBA report
here in the Rich Eisen show I would be
remiss because here we go here's Brady
again right he's he's now just using
whatever he can if you say he can't do
it at 40 let him throw for 5,000 yards
as a 40 year old which he's gonna do
I mean it's gonna happen so where does
he let's let's put on the oxygen masks
and go to a hundred thousand feet in the
Boston Pantheon here is he cuz you could
make the case we could have an argument
about the greatest Celtic of all time
potentially and we could potentially
have a greatest argument of the greatest
red sock of all time
there's no argument who the greatest
Patriot of all time is the greatest
Bruin because we're still the
transcended huh okay great where I get
it all the time and the Rushmore thing
yes he is number one he's on the fort
the Rushmore before sure you know the
four are Russell or Ted Williams and and
and Brady and Brady stand now here's a
great thing about the funny thing about
the Brady thing is until he came along I
used to maintain that the New England
Patriots were the only team in the
National Football League whose
greatest player in history by
acclimation was not a skilled position
player dare greatest player prior to Tom
Brady without any argument was John
Hannah an offensive guard and no other
team had that we reached down to the
offensive to the hog level he was to
identify their best player
they were so bereft of true stardom in
at the skilled positions nice players
but and then Brady radius you know if
he's the Gio 80 or not it he's in the
discussion and at that game on Sunday
that reminded me so much of the guy that
I in that he is the heir to the
spiritual heir to and that's Montana
that was a surgical precision dissection
of a team it wasn't I mean it was well
really when you agree to that that's
what it was it's not just that they're
playing at 7,000 feet then 20-year olds
are gonna be gassed he's 40 well you
know they don't follow the T b12
methodology properly he's not on the
avocado ice cream but but that's been so
easy one would you put him one all-time
Boston I won't because I'm a basketball
guy first and foremost so you get a
football guy and I'm sure we would but
Bill Russell is the greatest winner in
the history of North American sport
I'll give me the number that I always
give 21 times and his career starting
with that NCAA tournament we running
through the elliptical and metal round
games all best of fives and all best of
sevens 21 times he went and someone's
going home tonight he's 21 and oh I rest
my case on number one but and Brady it's
the thing about the Patriots in their
seven trips to the Super Bowl in a Brady
Belichick here with their five and two
they they could be Owen seven easily or
they could be seven and no easily all
the games were contested down that the
first three were field goal games that
the two giant miracle catch games and
which beat them in the last 30 seconds
of twice and then the Seattle Carroll
brain fart and then last year they could
have lost all those seven games and they
could have won all those seven games it
turns out he's five and two well up in
it he could be six and two by the time
we were in the middle of February Bob
love our chats love him thanks for
calling it my foot my pleasure to enjoy
that's it that's Bob Brown a kilo Bob
Ryan the rich eyes
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience